[Music]
almost three feet in diameter and a body
tough enough to survive a run-in with a
forklift this is no ordinary fan it's an
industrial fan they're designed to
circulate air in large spaces like
warehouses and factories production
starts with the motor a worker slides
the fans aluminum hub onto it then he
inserts wing-like blades known as air
foils into notches in the hub using a
hammer he taps the ends to set them in
the hub he places a part known as a
taper lock into a hole in the center the
taper lock will fasten the motor shaft
to the hub he screws the lip of the lock
to the hub next he installs a glass
reinforced plastic cone on the hub
this one secures the ends of the blades
in the hub he snaps a cap on to the
center of the nose cone now he transfers
the motor and hub assembly to a mount
that's in a heavy-duty plastic ring he
adds an upper mount and screws it to the
lower one he trims the outer ring of the
fan with rubber molding the rubber will
reduce vibration noise he lowers a steel
yoke onto the plastic surround and
attaches it with a screw he wires a
speed control mechanism to the fan motor
and fastens it to the outside of the
plastic surround he installs a plate
with a control knob on the front of the
speed control mechanism he screws on two
metal screens to the fans yoke this
forms a safety cage around the fan a
two-person crew bolts a wheeled pedestal
to the stem of the fan
[Music]
it's now ready to circulate to make an
industrial ceiling fan they use long
aluminum air foils their wind LED
profile will generate lift to produce
more air
a punch cuts holes to assemble them to a
hub a worker then attaches the main fan
assembly to the end of a long post in
order to facilitate the installation of
the long air foils then slides the air
foils onto spars that protrude from the
hub he reinforces the installation with
boomerang shaped metal retainers high
strength bolts secure the retainers and
air foils to the spars
he attaches plastic winglets to the ends
of the air foils the winglets will
direct air downward he installs a trim
ring on the hub this completes the
Assembly of the industrial ceiling fan
from this vantage point it seems pretty
cool
you